le 28 février dernier à peine quelques
jours après l'invasion russe en ukraine
le président volodymyr zelensky
présenter la demande d'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne
bientôt cette candidature sera examinée
par la commission européenne et
l'ukraine bénéficient d'un soutien de
poids quatre dirigeants européens ont
affiché leur soutien total à l'entrée du
pays dans l'union européenne
le cren appartient à la famille
européenne
au conseil européen je défendrai une
position unifiée
l'allemagne veut une décision positive
en faveur de l'ukraine
un large soutien qui s'explique par la
situation politique en allemagne le
chancelier allemand subit la pression de
ses partenaires de coalition pour que
l'ukraine ait des liens plus étroits
avec l'union européenne
dans cette affaire le président français
emmanuel macron joue également un rôle
important
la france assure actuellement la
présidence tournante du conseil de
l'union européenne ce qui lui confère le
pouvoir barbie très les débats entre les
états membres le mois dernier emmanuel
macron a lancé l'idée de créer une
communauté politique européenne comme
une sorte de solution intermédiaire à
l'adhésion mais la proposition a irrité
l'ukraine et certains états de l'est qui
ont vu une tentative de retarder le
processus cependant pour la première
fois le président français affiché son
soutien sans réserve à une candidature
immédiate de l'ukraine tous les quatre
nous soutenons le statut de candidat
immédiat l'adhésion à l'union européenne
pour l'ukraine ce vendredi la commission
européenne donnera son avis sur le
statut de la candidature de l'ukraine
les dirigeants européens devraient
prendre une décision la semaine
prochaine